our other top story tonight is shooting
leaves two children hurt and in the
hospital it happened just before four
this afternoon in a neighborhood near
Durango in the 95. Metro Police say a
boy and a girl were shot just outside
their house police believe the gunman
was driving by when those shots were
fired neighbors living there were
surprised something like this could
happen so close to home
this could have easily been one of our
children outside playing it's terrifying
and tragic this has always been a quiet
area which is why we chose it and
and now it's not I'm not surprised it's
scary you know it makes me nervous about
living in this neighborhood
both victims initially taken to nearby
Centennial Hills Hospital but later
transferred to UMC trauma one suffered
critical injuries we're told the other
is okay